let's go next to a treaties from Boston
A Treatise from Boston uh
uh what are you like a dune fan
uh yes I am very much I say this as I'm
sitting right next to my doing poster
all right well don't sit too close I can
hear you fine
uh excellent okay so I have a couple of
questions
um so Bernie in 2016 and 2020 ran and
you know almost got the nomination but
wasn't able to secure it but in doing
that he was able to sort of renew a
progressive movement within the country
and within the Democratic party
um and somewhat similar in my home state
of Massachusetts uh ranked Choice voting
was on the ballot back in 2020 and
um wasn't able to get past but now
countless more people that I talk to and
that I've interacted with and that I see
now know about rcvn support it
um I maybe will might seem a bit of an
optimist but do you think that there's
Merit in the byproduct of a loss that
eventually leads to some sort of Victory
or do you think those are more just
self-contained victories with like
limited success no sometimes that is the
case I mean it's very hard in any
particular situation to say could this
defeat actually be what eventually
Rockets us to a victory but in business
that's extraordinarily common where a
business will have an initial product or
service which fails and that allows them
to realize oh there's actually this
completely different way to do it
there's this better idea and were it not
for the failure if the initial failure
had instead been a modest success they
would have never come across the major
success and the same thing can happen
it's just hard in any particular case to
say okay does the failure of ranked
choice
mean that eventually it will be an even
bigger success it's so hard to say but
conceptually that's not an infrequent
occurrence something fails it lets you
reset and figure out the best way or the
right way or whatever and then you have
an even bigger success than you
otherwise would have had
great yeah no I definitely definitely
agree with you um New Coke for example
um yeah so I got that I've actually read
about that so coke introduced was New
Coke the one that was clear or it was
just the new flavor
no that's Crystal Pepsi New Coke was
like they sort of changed I might be
getting this a little wrong but New Coke
they like changed the recipe and tried
to like Rebrand Coke this was during
like the Cola Wars in the 80s and uh it
backfired badly so they brought back
Coke Classic and Coke Classic did much
much better than um than New Coke right
yep I've read extensively although it
was years ago about that that era it's
actually fascinating even as a non-soda
drinker generally speaking like myself
all right
um I did have a follow-up question sure
uh so as we know Biden is he's not very
popular right now I I believe that
recent polls said that 71 of of
Americans uh don't want him to seek
reelection which isn't doesn't spell
great for the Democrats in 2024 uh and
I've heard Whispers And murmurs that
Gavin Newsom would be in his uh in his
absence if he doesn't seek re-election
something that I've I'm not I don't
really have much to back this up it's
more just a hypothesis but I'm worried
that the DNC was sort of panic and
they'd find a moderate Democrat or
somebody who's maybe not so moderate
um like Tulsi gabbard for example who no
if you see she has not I I was worried
they were just going to just throw her
to the front because he's not even a
Democrat at this point if the DNC
certainly might anoint someone they
might say we're anointing Kamala in Joe
Biden's absence on the ticket or who
whoever but they're not going to go to
Tool C tool sees essentially a
republican she spoke at CPAC you know
yeah she's [ __ ] CPAC it's crazy now
that don't worry about that that's not
gonna happen
okay yeah uh just like a
just a general hypothesis I said yeah
but uh yeah that thank you for taking my
call my pleasure great to hear from you
there goes A Treatise from Boston great
to speak to people that does it for
today but we will take calls again